[Music]
commencing teleportation process in
three
two back to the sci-fi section
at last you know with as many issues as
i have with the expanded dune books
there's a lot that i like as well
and following in the footsteps of frank
herbert is not an easy task to say the
least
what is that ah
not again i should really turn my phone
off when i'm in here
hmm looks like i'm getting a new
trans-dimensional message
time for a new dune video eh ah
let's get to that
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry about the robes guys they're
from a different thing
as a matter of fact computer generate a
more appropriate
outfit generating outfit in three two
okay uh okay not my usual hat but okay
it'll work for now i guess
i like this shirt though so if you're
out of the loop there are six
original frank herbert dune books doom
the original
big boy the classic the one everybody
knows
dune messiah the less liked and less
known sequel
children of dune the epic end of the
first trilogy which is much more like
the first book
god emperor of dune a weird
philosophical book about a guy that
turns into a worm it's long story watch
my video on it heretics of dune
and chapter house dune which were
actually meant to be the first two books
in the second dune trilogy but frank
herbert unfortunately died
before he could finish the trilogy after
the death of frank herbert brian herbert
and kevin j
anderson released a slew of new dune
books
sequels prequels all set to be based at
least somewhat on notes in which frank
herbert
left behind and there is a lot of these
guys there is a lot of dissent in the
fandom actually as to whether or not
these books are any good
to see my opinion on it check out this
video right here
but whether or not those books are any
good are not the point of this video
what we're here to talk about today is
the brand new
dune trilogy that brian herbert and
kevin g anderson are coming out with
next based entirely on duke lato
the lady jessica and young paul atreides
let's get into the news that we have for
it right now all right guys so first
we're going to take a look at this
article from cbr.com
new dune trilogy launches in october
with publication of the duke of kaladan
writers brian herbert and kevin j
anderson will publish the duke of
calidan
this october kicking off a trilogy which
leads up to the events of dune
so as you can see guys this is a prequel
trilogy
based on the planet kaladan which is the
ancestral homeworld
of house of tradies and continuing with
this article
the novel dune has inspired several
spin-offs and prequels in the years
since its publication
and now a new trilogy will directly lead
into the events of the first novel
brian herbert the son of dune's late
author frank herbert made the
announcement that he
and his frequent collaborator kevin j
anderson will be writing the trilogy
kevin and i are pleased to announce a
new trilogy for tour books focused on
duke lato
lady jessica and paul leading directly
into the events of dune
we've written the first novel the duke
of kaladan to be released
october 13th cover art to be revealed
soon all right guys so all we really got
here is an
amazon link and there's not much
information other than the information
that's right in the front it is a
prequel
it is about house of treaties on caledon
specifically
lato jessica and paul so obviously these
will be the events
after brian herbert and kevin j
anderson's book house atreides
and hopefully this will offer an
opportunity to expand upon the
characters
even more now i know for a fact there
are a lot of you out there that don't
really trust brian herbert and kevin j
anderson to do that
so many of you are bound to be more
excited than others
alright and that's it for brian
herbert's new dune trilogy moving on to
our next bit of do
news alright so remember when i said a
while ago that the first dune footage
was going to be shown on july
17th during the re-release of inception
well that date has passed
and no dune footage has been shown
so that is kind of worrisome to say the
least
the more and more things continue to
move in the direction that they have
moved in america pretty much exclusively
it's looking less and less like we're
going to be seeing the release of dune
at the end of the year even though they
haven't announced it i doubt that
theaters are going to be able to open
nationally by december 18th
but that's just my prediction we'll see
what actually happens
but i know this is a hard truth but i
think that it would be pretty reasonable
for us to
start looking at this like a 2021 movie
and not keeping our hopes that we're
definitely gonna get it in december
because i don't know if that's gonna
happen and i've been expressing this
fear for quite some time now
and it's looking more and more like that
is probably the case which is
extraordinarily sad
it is endlessly sad but we'll get this
movie eventually
and it's gonna be awesome and i'm
excited for it
and although i'm sure a lot of you
aren't excited for it i'm also excited
for brian herbert's new trilogy i'm
excited to open it up
and see what it's all about so in
conclusion will brian herbert's new
trilogy be worth the read
the hell is that shut the hell up
um who are you i am organism 9186 from
the planet trolling on 897 and i declare
that you're wrong and this video sucks
okay thanks for your opinion but this is
my private dimension and i need you to
leave
now this video is trash you don't know
what you're talking about the expanded
dune books are better than the originals
everyone is entitled to their opinion if
you really love the brian herbert books
read them
enjoy them oh you're so pretentious all
you do is complain this is just like how
you did nothing but complaining about
the last four seasons of game of thrones
why don't you just do us all a favor and
delete your channel also that hat is
even stupider than your usual hat what
second rate ai system dreamed that one
up and also no one cares about your book
stop talking about it no one gives a
[ __ ] the new woke dude movie is gonna
suck it's sjw garbage and lee kinds is a
male
everyone knows that's enough computer
eject foreign
all right like i was saying so in
conclusion
will the brian herbert books be worth
the read well i think that's for every
individual person to decide for
themselves
we won't know until we pick them up and
actually try them but i will say this if
you didn't enjoy the earlier brian
herbert kevin j
anderson books for reasons like it not
being canonically accurate exactly
or them just stylistically being written
differently from the way frank herbert
wrote his original dune books
then you're probably not going to enjoy
the new trilogy but if you're a
completionist like me then you're going
gonna try it anyway regardless and i'm
definitely gonna be giving it a try
and probably reviewing the new trilogy
on this channel
all right guys that's all we got for
today but coming up next i've been
reading a bunch of isaac asimov's
foundation
books brushing up on all the details
i've got a very cool video on trantor
coming up very soon so stay tuned for
that guys
and then after that we're going to get a
bit lovecraftian with my video essay on
the call of cthulhu by hp lovecraft
which you guys have been anticipating
for a while now and even more
anticipated
ultimate guide to chapter house it is on
the horizon guys
as soon as i finish my lovecraft video i
am shifting all of my focus
to getting back into this chapter house
of dune video and finishing it out for
you guys
chapter house is coming guys it's been a
busy year
or so i mean time gets weird in this
interdimensional thing that i'm in here
so it's a little i think it's been about
a year
it's been a weird year since uh ultimate
guide to heretics of dune came out i
haven't had a lot of time to work on
this
you know the tadia book my graphic novel
coming out
and then so much else the pandemic and
yada yada yada it's been busy but we're
getting to it
it's coming get excited thanks for
watching guys
[Music]
[Music]
you